- Pour confectionner ces jeans
français, il faut compter sur
ces employées, qui maîtrisent
les arts du métier.
Mais a s s sur des alliées
incontournables dans le procédé:
des machines très gourmandes
en énergie.
- Ici, c'est une étape
qui est très énergivore
dans le processus de tissage.
- Chez Tissages de France,
les factures de gaz
et d'électricité ont explosé.
THOMAS HURIEZ, patron,
Tissage de France
- On avait en 2021,
400 000 euros d'énergie
sur 4 millions de chiffre
d'affaires. On va dire 10 %.
En 2022, ce 400 000 euros
est devenu 900 000 euros,
c'est-à-dire presque 25 %
du chiffre d'affaires.
Et en 2023, au prix
d'aujourd'hui, ce serait
2 millions d'euros.
C'est tellement énorme
que ce n'est pas possible.
- Pour réduire ces immenses
dépenses, l'entreprise
a dû ralentir le rythme.
Pendant tout le mois
de septembre, les activités
ont été suspendues le lundi
et le vendredi : une stratégie
qui a permis de diminuer
la consommation, mais
qui a aussi eu des impacts
sur le personnel.
- Le chômage partiel, ça peut
faire du bien économiquement,
mais ça désorganise. Ça demande
beaucoup d'agilité, beaucoup
de souplesse à toute l'équipe.
Ça peut faire peur aussi.
Donc, c'est jamais de gaieté
de coeur qu'on fait ce choix-là.
Mais on a expliqué ouououte
l'équipe pourquoi on faisait
ça, pour notre avenir.
- Il n'y a pas que
les entreprises qui sont
frappées de plein fouet
par l'explosion des prix
de l'énergie. Les villes et
municipalités à travers le pays
voient aussi les impacts sur
leur budget. Ici à Varangéville,
dans l'est de la France,
on a par exemple d
de réduire la consommation
énergétique, et ce, avant même
que le gouvernement français
fasse des recommandations
à ce sujet.
La communauté de 3700 habitants
a accéléré un virage vert
qui avait déjà été prévu.
Dans cette ville industrielle
en transformation, il fallait
absolument limiter les dépenses
énergétiques. Sans quoi,
c'est le tiers de la capacité
annuelle d'investissement
qui aurait disparu.
CHRISTOPHER VARIN,
maire de Varangéville
- Le contexte géopolitique
et la crise du gaz russe ont
contribué à nous faire accélérer
dans les prises de décisions,
a complètement changé nos plans
d'investmemement pour réaliser
un maximum d'économies
le plus tôt possible,
parce que l'explosion des prix
de l'énergie nous contraint
énormément budgétairement
parlant si on n'agit pas.
- Pour éviter le gaspillage,
la ville entend mieux isoler
certains de ses édifices,
comme ce centre sportif.
- Cet éclairage, qui est
très énergivore...
- Dès cette année, on y changera
ces vieux panneaux lumineux
pour les remplacer par des
lampes DEL, qui consomment
beupupup moins.
- Donc, on passera sur de
l'éclairage blanc moderne...
- Dans l'immédiat, les autorités
ont déjà réalisé d'importantesé:
baisse du chauffage
dans les édifices municipaux
et fermeture de l'éclairage
public à partir de minuit.
Le jour se lève à peine
quand Arnaud Huin entreprendsa x
clients à visiter pendant
sa tournée.
ARNAUD HUIN,
employé de Piskorski
- Je n'ai jamais vu un tel
engouement pour le bois.
- L'entreprise pour laquelle il
travaille vend des granulés de
bois utilisés pour se chauffer.
Vu la demande, en un an,
la valeur d'un sac
comme celui-ci est passé
de 4 à plus de 10 euros.
Les bonnes vieilles bûches
de bois ont elles aussi connu
un regain de popularité.
- On produit actuellement
600 stères par semaine.
Et cela ne suffit pas encore
pour alimenter tous les foyers.
Donc on est obligé de rationner.
Pas plus de six stères
par client. Les client
qui commandent actuellement
ne seront livrés qu'en début
d'année 2023.
- Certains clients pourront
compter sur une bonne réserve
pour se chauffer cet hiver.
- C'est comme des lingots d'or.
Chaque bûche est comme
un lingot.
- Cette année, il a doublé
ses achats de bois, question
de moins avoir recours au gaz
dont dépend aussi sa résidence.
- C'est l'année où on a consommé
le moins de gaz et on a payé
probablement 50 % de plus
l'année dernière, que les années
précédentes. Donc oui,
ça a vraiment explosé.
- Dans les locaux de Tissages
de France, ce mois-ci,
les activités ont repris du
lundi au vendredi. Mais ici,
on sait que l'industrie n'est
pas à l'abri d'autres défis,
d'où l'intérêt de bien
s'y préparer.
Certaines machines énergivores
seront changées; les systèmesde.
- On n'aura jamais investi
collectivement autant
dans les économies d'énergie
qu'aujourd'hui où l'énergie
augmente. Quelque part, c'est un
peu malheureux d'attendre d'être
au pied du mur pour investir
sur des solutions de bon sens
pour l'environnement et même
pour l'aspect financier.
- Dans le secteur public
ou privé, c'est une voie
que beaucoup en Europe semblent
maintenant emprunter.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, Rupt-sur-Mosell